[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Hi,
everybody, and welcome
to "TensorFlow Meets."
In this episode, I'm
chatting with Haohan Wang--
HAOHAN WANG: Thank you
for having me here.
LAURENCE MORONEY: --who's
been doing some really,
really cool work with
neuroscience, and TensorFlow,
and machine learning, and
all kinds of cool stuff,
and even a new course.
So you've been working
on Dyad X Machina, which
is a beautiful name for what
looks like a beautiful site.
Could you tell us all about it?
HAOHAN WANG: Sure.
So I will start from
the name Dyad X Machina.
Dyad means two as
one, which is me
and my partner, Christian Fanli.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And Christian is
going to be on a future
show, which is great.
HAOHAN WANG: Yes.
So machine-- things we
constantly work with machine.
And we're at the intersection
of deep learning and affective
computing.
So as for why we
started Dyad X Machina,
I think the story really
starts four to five years ago
when we first met.
So I was a student
in finance and he was
working in human behavior area.
And we started to
collaborate because we
both shared the same strong
interest in machine learning.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
HAOHAN WANG: So one of the
first machine learning projects
that we worked on together is
to create a trading algorithms.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
HAOHAN WANG: Well, so
Christian challenged
us to think outside
the box instead
of using the traditional
technical or fundamental
analysis into your
algorithm, why can't we
add some human behavioral
elements, like emotions,
into your algorithm?
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
HAOHAN WANG: Well, so
we end up including
sentiment into our algorithm.
And surprisingly, sentiment
is a great training--
a very indicative
training signals.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I can
see that because I'm
sure when some
people are buying,
then everybody jumps on board.
And when some
people are selling,
everybody-- you know,
that kind of thing.
There's a lot of sentiment.
HAOHAN WANG: Yeah, early signal.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Yeah, definitely.
HAOHAN WANG: Yeah.
Well, so after that, I think
it really brought emotion
into our attention.
And then we started
to study a lot more
into this field, affective
neuroscience especially.
And we read numerous
book in the field.
And I think we started to
notice a problem, which
is how society at large tends
to ignore how important emotion
is, especially like in our
daily decision-making process
because people tend
to overvalue cognition
and rationality over emotion.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Interesting.
HAOHAN WANG: Yeah.
So I think, well, that's really
the starting point that we
think probably it's our job--
it's Dyad X Machina's job to
bring this affective layer back
into people's daily life.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So it's
you saw an opportunity
to bring emotion into
what are traditionally
logical decisions?
HAOHAN WANG: Yep.
There is where Dyad X
Machina started, yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Interesting.
And now, a lot of
the work that you've
been doing and a
lot of the learning
that you've been doing,
you're turning into a course
now, right?
HAOHAN WANG: Yes.
So start from there
actually-- well,
here is where deep learning
and TensorFlow came in.
So we were studying
machine learning,
but then we discovered
deep learning.
So I think so here is also the
point that we hit a point that
we cannot make any more progress
because we're both working full
time and we'd dedicate all our
free time on reading books--
LAURENCE MORONEY: Those day
jobs just get in the way,
don't they?
HAOHAN WANG: Yep-- trying to
understand machine learning
and affective computing.
So I think we had a discussion
and made a hard decision--
I took one year off, focused
fully on deep learning
and affective computing.
So here, you can
think of this course--
and we end up making this course
because this course is really
the synthesis of our
learning because we really
dedicated a lot
of time and effort
on learning deep learning.
And we think this course will
be a great start for people
who are new to deep
learning to get started.
But more importantly,
I think our main focus
is to help people who want to
use deep learning to the field
that they are passionate about
to be able to get started.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
your course is about
applied deep learning with
TensorFlow and Cloud AI?
HAOHAN WANG: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
There's a lot in there.
So what kind of
content do you have?
HAOHAN WANG: Well, so this
is our very first course.
And we're a little
bit ambitious trying
to put everything in there.
But the course is
really meant to help
people who are new
to machine learning
to be able to build their
first deep learning model
and to take it all
the way to deploy
their model as
production-level API.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
HAOHAN WANG: Then
we move on to talk
about the basics
of deep learning
and how to design an experiment
with some typical neural
networks using Keras.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Keras, yep.
HAOHAN WANG: Yep.
And then we move on-- we
dove deep into TensorFlow.
We start from
low-level TensorFlow.
We introduce the concept
like dataflow graph
and a TensorBoard, then we move
on to high-level TensorFlow.
Then help people to build
a model in the cloud,
train the model,
evaluate the model,
and eventually
deploy their model
as a production-level API.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
the deployment part
is really fascinating
to me because there's
lots of great material out there
about training models and maybe
doing a little bit of a test,
but making it real world,
making it applied
is really cool.
HAOHAN WANG: Yeah, that's
our intention-- help people
to apply it to the field
they're interested in.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
And we'll put a link to the
course in the comments below.
So you've started
with neuroscience,
and then you've moved into
taking a year off and creating
a course.
And you've obviously gotten
very deep into machine learning
and you've gotten very
deep into neuroscience
and the intersection
between the two of them.
What advice would
you give to people
who are just starting out?
HAOHAN WANG: Well, yes.
So I'd like to talk a little
bit about-- connect it back
to our learning experience
of a journey of deep learning
and possible a little bit
about affective neuroscience.
So we also summarize
this four P's
of learning that I'd
like to share here.
LAURENCE MORONEY: The
four P's of learning?
HAOHAN WANG: Well, yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK, I'll
try to remember them myself.
HAOHAN WANG: We published
an article on our website
so people can check it out.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Ah, so
we've got a link for that,
so I don't need to remember it.
HAOHAN WANG: Yeah, and you
don't have to remember it.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Great.
HAOHAN WANG: So the first
P-- papers and books.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Papers, OK.
HAOHAN WANG: Well, I think
it's really the foundation
because we make
sure we read papers
and books every single day.
And we got up 4:30 AM, the
first task is to read paper.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow.
HAOHAN WANG: Yeah,
deep learning papers.
So at the beginning,
we read some more
like basic deep
learning paper to know
what is trending in the field
or how people solve problems
with deep learning.
Then we move on to be more
specific about our domain--
how people use deep
learning to solve
like neuroscience problems--
affective neuroscience
problems?
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
4:30 AM for the first P?
HAOHAN WANG: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I think
you've lost me already.
HAOHAN WANG: Yeah, first day.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Just kidding.
So papers.
And what was the second?
HAOHAN WANG: Paper and books.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And books, yeah.
HAOHAN WANG: Well,
paper and books.
Second P is practice.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Practice, OK.
HAOHAN WANG: Yeah, so I think
practice is very important.
Especially like
I think I am very
passionate about
like every day, I
will use TensorFlow
to build some--
start from the basic
neural networks
and understand like
dataflow graph.
And like, I'm very interested in
using TensorBoard to visualize
my training, and
evaluating resource,
and how to tune my
model's hyperparameters.
So I think then practice.
And you can find those
problems very easily
on Kaggle and Crowd AI.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Kaggle, right.
Yep.
HAOHAN WANG: So the third
P, which I think personally
is very helpful for my
learning, which is preach.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Preach, OK.
HAOHAN WANG: Yeah, you can
think of lecturing or teaching.
So every day, I
will give Christian
a mini-lecture about what
I learned during the day
about deep learning,
some theories,
or even neural network
I built that day.
So I think it's
mutually beneficial.
It helped me to
consolidate my knowledge
and helped him to have
an overview about what
I learned and also making
some progress from his side.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Excellent.
HAOHAN WANG: Well,
last P, we think
is really helping us to
get where we are right
now is passion.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah.
They definitely need passion.
HAOHAN WANG: Yeah.
So well, first like
I mentioned, we
saw this great potential of
deep learning and TensorFlow
that you can leverage to really
bring the transformative change
into the domain because
this is new technology.
And regularly in
the past, at least
based on our study about
the effect of neuroscience,
no one has ever
leveraged this technology
to build any algorithm yet.
So we set out to
make that happen.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So bringing
emotion into algorithms.
HAOHAN WANG: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: It
sounds fascinating.
So you started this
journey as you were
doing financial trading stuff--
HAOHAN WANG: Yep.
LAURENCE MORONEY: --and then
you just took a look at emotions
in that.
You know, from out of that
has grown Dyad X Machina.
HAOHAN WANG: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
now, you have a course.
You have your daily four
P's that you're doing.
It's like there's a lot
of amazing stuff there.
So what's next for Haohan?
HAOHAN WANG: Yeah, so next
for me and Dyad X Machina
is we're right
now, still working
on running experiments
every day and doing research
in affective computing area.
We're trying to
put things together
to be able to eventually
present to the-- share
with the community.
So we will be working on
this part of the study.
What's more is another
thing about the course.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
HAOHAN WANG: We are planning
to make a new course.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh, wow.
HAOHAN WANG: And we plan
to deliver the course
by the end of this year or
the beginning of next year.
The course will be called
"Affective Computing
and Deep Learning
using TensorFlow."
LAURENCE MORONEY: "Affective
Computing and Deep Learning
using TensorFlow?"
HAOHAN WANG: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I'll
look forward to it.
HAOHAN WANG: Yeah.
So in this course, we
will be teaching people
how to use TensorFlow and
the Google Cloud machine
learning engine to stream
in your psychophysiological
signals over time and
to process your signals.
And eventually, the
algorithm should
be able to make a
real-time prediction
about your affective state.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK, excellent.
So your course on
affective computing,
it's going to be coming out
pretty soon-- maybe the end
of this year or sometime
early next year.
And maybe after the
course comes out,
we'll have you on
again to talk about it.
HAOHAN WANG: Yes,
I would love to.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
we'll look forward to it.
So thanks so much, Haohan.
And thanks, everybody,
for watching this episode
of "TensorFlow Meets."
If you have any questions
for me or if you
have any questions for
Haohan, please just
leave them in the
comments below.
And whatever you
do, don't forget
to hit that Subscribe button.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]